[Music]
okay here we go so the first they all
pertain all these three questions with
dave challenge are going to pertain in
some sense to sir arthur c clarke who's
the namesake of the organization that
i'm representing here at uc san diego um
and and the first thing you know that uh
arthur c clarke said is any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic that's kind of a hallmark
signature line of his and of course you
know
creating a simulation or something could
be even indistinguishable from god uh
and i want to talk about mortality in
the first question not to be too down on
a friday morning friday afternoon for
you but um when you leave this mortal
coil at age 120 in the biblical
tradition the age that moses reached um
i want to ask you what would you leave
as an ethical will as a as what we in
hebrew call a zaba ah a collection of
wisdom or knowledge not necessarily um
you know financial advice to uh you
don't have children but to your uh
ideological children of which there are
probably millions around the the
universe so what piece of wisdom would
you leave to such individuals
about yeah when it comes to thinking
about values and ethics like i'm not
religious but i do believe in meaning
and value in life i guess i think that
meaning and value of our lives
we have meaning and value in our lives
because we are conscious creatures
and we can invest things around us with
meaning for us and with value don't look
at you know something in the world to
provide its value for you don't look to
uh don't look necessarily
to a god or to a to a politician or to a
mystic to provide your value for you i
think we invest things with meaning and
meaning is the human mind has this
amazing capacity to invest things with
meaning and i think you know good
meaning
meaning
the material object
um or knowledge not in wisdom now now
we're talking about knowledge um that
you would put on your monolith so you
may have seen 2001 a space odyssey where
these hominids they encounter this
enormous monolith and they want to
engrave something on it or they want to
understand what's in it maybe it's a
time capsule maybe it's a weapon who
knows what it is
but i want to ask you if you had a time
capsule that you knew was going to last
for a billion years not 120 years
you got this time capsule what would you
put on it what would you put in it what
would you use uh you know you could put
a cd-rom from aol on it i don't care
what would you put on in it around it
about it to encapsulate the grandeur of
what human beings have achieved
yeah interesting it's kind of hard to
put a philosophical slogan into a uh
onto the uh under the time capsule but i
guess if i really wanted to be
informative and to tell them about us
i would try and stick a human brain in
there if it's not it's hard to to uh
to uh freeze a human brain and put it in
there maybe you'll just put the best
possible
record of a brain image of the human
brain in there such that they could
reconstruct
a human brain not only i mean a that
would provide the possibility of
reanimation and a form of immortality
for the uh for the human species but b
it could actually tell them what we're
all about in a much
in a much better way than uh than simply
producing a few artifacts i mean maybe
if there's room for a bit more i'll put
our best ai program and maybe uh maybe a
smartphone
show them where uh
show them show them our technology but
yeah the human brain if we can
reactivate the human brain to reactivate
human consciousness i think that would
be a pretty worthy worthy purpose for a
time capsule
i was afraid you might say the collected
works of olivia newton-john uh let's get
physical
you know she was max paul's
granddaughter i know that yeah
let's get
it from bit let's get simulational uh
okay the last question david now we're
going into the past and to your past
specifically and i'm going to ask you uh
a question pertinent to uh sir arthur c
clarke's third law so i gave you his
first law about magic and uh technology
my second law was for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert i
like to pull that on my department chair
or you can tell that to greg gabadzi and
my friend gregory
yeah yeah yeah he's a good good friend
pull that out on him you know if he
makes you you or your colleagues teach
too much but his third law uh states
that the only way
of determining the limits of the
possible is to go a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the
reason and the namesake of this podcast
into the impossible so i'll ask you what
sort of mysterious aspect of your life
specifically perplexed you
as a 20 year old a 30 year old and what
advice would you give to him if he could
go back in time and reprogram the
simulation
what would you give him to give him the
confidence to go as you've gone into the
impossible
oh boy i don't know i guess that's um
yeah the central mystery for me has
always been in consciousness and yeah in
a certain sense consciousness does just
kind of seem impossible
a physical universe with a physical
brain
so why on earth would that give you this
amazing experience of consciousness it
just seems at least impossible at least
given certain natural assumptions but
it's nonetheless the most important most
familiar things
thing in our life so you know the most
familiar things are often the most
mysteriously a consciousness seems
impossible but i guess i would like to
say
we can rigor we can reason rigorously
even in thinking about the impossible
the mysterious
the speculative
the grandiose
there's nothing stopping you even if
it's not yet ready for science that
doesn't mean it's not yet ready
for reason and you know one thing we try
and do in philosophy is to try and
reason about these things and to figure
out what the possibilities are so okay
you don't so
yeah you don't need to solve a problem
in order to make progress on
on understanding it and i just tell that
younger version of myself just go
full steam ahead try and understand the
impossible never give up on reason
well that is wonderful and a wonderful
way to end after a fascinating
conversation with one of the world's
foremost thinkers david chalmers nyu
author of reality plus i i really
commend it to your attention and uh
you've earned a spot in the pantheon of
of some of my favorite interviews of all
time dave thank you so much for joining
us and spending your valuable time with
my audience thanks brian this was a
great conversation
[Music]
you